depuis le début de la crise due
de 19 et en fait
m.bien avance
la de nombreuses informations
circulent à foison sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans les médias parfois il
s'agit de désinformation dangereuse qui
doivent être ensuite des construite par
des instituts comme l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
mais souvent ces informations ne sont
pas fausses ou stupide
bien souvent elles sont même juste mais
elles sont trompeuses en particulier
trop souvent le vrai problème c'est le
fait que des conclusions beaucoup trop
univoque sont tirés de données et
d'hypothèses pourtant incomplète biaisé
ou sujettes à l'incontournable paradoxe
de simpson est encore une fois si vous
ne connaissez pas le paradoxe de simpson
mettez pose sérieusement est allé voir
cette vidéo de cette vidéo
oui car en prétendant trop peu attention
aux innombrables pièges des statistiques
trop de discours semble mal mesuré
l'étendue de leur ignorance manqué
gravement de modestie épistémique et
souffrir d'un nid aube excès de
confiance très trompeur et non quand je
dis ça je ne pense pas qu'elle ait
discours d'ignace incompétent et
méprisable quand je dis ça je pense à
vous qui regardez cette vidéo est à moi
et mes innombrables pêché depuis le
début de la crise l'excès de confiance
est un fléau qui frappe chacun d'entre
nous nous sommes en excès de confiance
y compris les meilleurs parmi nous comme
l'expliquent les psychologues dominique
& johnson et james fowler les humains ou
de nombreux biais psychologiques mais
l'un des plus récurrent des plus
puissants et des plus répandus c'est
l'excès de confiance
l'excès de confiance j'en ai été
beaucoup trop souvent beaucoup trop
victimes y compris ces derniers temps
par exemple dans ma première vidéo sur
le colis de 10,9 alors même que
j'insiste est sûre les normes
incertitudes qu'il y avait autour de
cette nouvelle maladie
j'ai estimé à ce moment de la vidéo un
intervalle de crédence bien trop étroit
par rapport à l'étendue de mon ignorance
par chance on m'a fait la remarque à ce
sujet j'ai pu rajouter une note qui
corrige mon estimation de l'incertitude
mais avant cette remarque clairement
j'étais en excès de confiance et ça
c'est un exemple qui a passé le filtre
du pire vidéo review ring que j'ai
appliqué abondamment ces derniers temps
or je peux vous garantir que ce pire
vidéo red bull ring a coupé énormément
d'excès de confiance dont les premiers
gels de mes scripts étaient remplis le
problème c'est que surtout en ce moment
cet excès de confiance a des
conséquences dramatiques
il peut conduire à des décisions
politiques précipitée et mal réfléchi à
des débats plus destructive que
constructif et un manque d'anticipation
des cas extrêmes ignorés par notre excès
de confiance en particulier cet excès de
confiance a sans doute contribué à un
manque de préparation et de déploiement
des mesures nécessaires pour contenir la
crise du coronavirus comme l'appel
massif à la distanciation sociale et aux
gestes barrières un confinement plus
précoce pour ralentir bien plus vite le
coronavirus et un investissement
important dans des ressources humaines
et matériel médical
l'excès de confiance tu à l'échelle
internationale rien qu'en terme de mort
directe du coc vide 19 on peut même sans
doute d'ores et déjà lui imputer des
milliers de nord en espérant qu'on
n'atteigne pas des millions de morts il
est urgent qu'on traite chacun d'entre
nous notre propre excès de confiance
que vous soyez politiciens journalistes
vulgarisateur tweetos lambda ou
scientifique
s'il vous plaît combattez votre excès de
confiance
et oui j'ai aussi mis les scientifiques
dans le panier car eux aussi sont très
probablement en graves excès de
confiance
en fait la semaine dernière j'ai été
effaré est absolument terrifiée de voir
à quel point
l'excès de confiance touche gravement
des experts en épidémiologie propre nom
les 16 et 17 mars 18 experts mondiaux en
épidémiologie dont voici les noms ont
été interrogés par un sondage qui leur
demanda de prédire le plus petit le plus
probable est le plus grand nombre de cas
total aux états unis que le colis de
tracking apportera le 29 mars
leur réponse tient dans ce graphe sur ce
graphe chaque point bleu et la
prédiction la plus probable selon un
expert et chaque bar d'erreur correspond
à l'incertitude de l'expert sachant ce
graphe où se trouvent selon vous où
nombre de cas effectivement confirmé le
29 mars ici là les experts ont-ils vu
juste et bien avant de vous le dire je
vais d'abord me permettre de faire
d'ores et déjà deux remarques très
embarrassantes sur ses bars d'erreurs la
première c'est que ces barres d'erreur
seul suggère déjà que beaucoup d'experts
ont une très très
mauvaise compréhension de la croissance
exponentielle et ça c'est très
embarrassant mais c'est surtout flippant
je m'explique traçant un graphe en
abscisse on a le nombre de jours depuis
le premier cas confirmé en ordonnée on a
le nombre de cas mais sur une échelle
logarithmique autrement dit chaque fois
qu'on monte d'une unité
on multiplie en fait par dix le nombre
de cas l'intérêt de cette échelle peu
usuelle c'est que si une croissance est
parfaitement exponentielle alors elle
sera représentée par une droite
mieux encore la pente de cette droite
c'est à dire à quel point elle grimpe
verticalement correspond à différents
taux de croissance cette droite qui
correspond à doubler tous les deux jours
celle-là a doublé tous les trois jours
et celle là a doublé tous les cinq jours
le fabuleux side en holding d'état a
utilisé ce graphe pour proposer une
merveilleuse illustration du rythme de
progression de la pandémie
voici ce que ça donne de façon
remarquable la chine et la corée du sud
ont réussi à freiner beaucoup la
croissance du nombre de cas confirmés
même si techniquement la croissance
reste encore légèrement exponentielle
tout cas pour la corée du sud l'italie
la france et la suisse commencent eux
aussi à aplatir leurs courbes ce qui
montre que les effets du confinement
commence à se faire ressentir
les etats unis aussi semble enfin
ralentir cependant pendant très
longtemps leur nombre de cas confirmés
doublait tous les deux jours et demi
avec néanmoins beaucoup de fluctuations
et donc beaucoup d'incertitudes sur ce
temps de doublement bref les croissances
jusque là sous tend gros exponentielle
avec des fluctuations du taux de
croissance surtout tant que les effets
du confinement ne se font pas sentir
et tant qu'on est encore loin de
l'immunité de groupe et ça c'est crucial
à prendre en compte pour construire
l'intervalle de crédence imaginons
maintenant que le nombre de cas
confirmés aujourd'hui et 4000 ce qui
était le cas aux états unis le 16 mars
est maintenant admettons qu'on soit
incertain sur le taux de croissance
qu'il y aura aux états unis dans les
treize jours qui suivront et admettons
que cette incertitude soit grande qu on
hésitait entre un doublement tous les
deux jours et un doublement tous les
huit jours et bien dans le premier cas
avec un doublement tous les deux jours
le nombre de cas dans 13 jours seraient
quatre mille fois deux puissances 13 / 2
qui est égal à 360 milles environ
dans le second cas avec nous
tous les huit jours il serait de quatre
mille fois deux puissances 13 / 8 ce qui
est de l'ordre de 12 mille noté l'écart
énorme de prédiction que cela fait un
simple facteur 4 dans l'incertitude sur
le temps de doublement a conduit à une
incertitude d'un facteur 30 dans la
prédiction
oui un facteur 30
mais ce que je veux surtout vous montrer
c'est ce qui se passe si je prends la
valeur moyenne entre un doublement tous
les deux jours et un doublement tous les
huit jours
on obtient alors doublement tous les
cinq jours ce qui me fait prédire 4000
fois deux puissances 13 / 5 qui est de
l'ordre de 24 mille étrange non
on a pris le taux de croissance moyen
entre les valeurs extrêmes et donc a
priori le plus probable mais ce taux de
croissance moyen donne une valeur
beaucoup plus proche de la borne basse
de 12000 que de la borne haute de 360
milles et bien ça c'est une propriété
des croissances exponentielles les cas
extrêmes de croissance très rapide sont
très extrême car une petite variation
positive du taux de croissance a des
effets monumentaux et l'effet est
d'autant plus marqué que l'incertitude
sur le taux de croissance est important
pour visualiser l'effet de l'incertitude
dans cette figure j'ai ainsi représenter
des prédictions probabiliste qu'on
serait amené à faire si on pense que le
temps de doublement est de l'ordre de 5
jours et si on mesure petit à petit
l'étendue de notre ignorance en
combattant notre excès de confiance
comme vous le voyez pour une plus grande
incertitude sur le taux de croissance
les cas extrêmes deviennent 10 plus
probable et surtout beaucoup plus
extrêmes
dans le jargon on parle de cygne noir ou
de queues de distribution épaisse dans
le cas de cette figure j'ai décrit le
taux de croissance par une loi normale
ce qui fait que le nombre de cas dans 13
jours suis une distribution qu'on
appelle log normal les détails importe
peu ce qui importe c'est que pour une
telle loi surtout si le taux de
croissance est grand et si l'incertitude
sur ce taux de croissance est grande
le pic de la distribution c'est à dire
lequel plus probable qu'on appelle aussi
le mode de la distribution est très à
gauche par rapport à l'ensemble de la
distribution en particulier si une autre
incertitude est décrite par une telle
courbe notre meilleure estimation doit
correspondre au pic et elle doit donc se
trouver très à gauche dans notre
intervalle de claix danse en fait il est
même possible que ce mode se trouve à
l'extérieur d'un intervalle qui coupe
les 10% les plus extrêmes des deux côtés
dit autrement la borne haute de notre
incertitudes devraient être beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus préoccupante que
la prédiction la plus probable une barre
d'erreur conforme à la croissance
exponentielle
ça doit ressembler à quelque chose comme
cela
or de façon très embarrassante
à peine la moitié des experts interrogés
ou des intervalles de crédence conforme
avec cet aspect des croissances
exponentielles
et ça je trouve ça terrifiant car cela
suggère que les experts en épidémiologie
ont une compréhension très incomplète de
la croissance exponentielle en
particulier cette compréhension bancal
soulève le risque qu'ils sous-estiment
gravement la probabilité des cas
extrêmes surtout s'ils sont déjà en
excès de confiance sur le taux de
croissance en effet j insiste encore
dessus quand une distribution et l'ogg
normal augmenté l'incertitude sur le
taux de croissance ça élargit
radicalement l'intervalle de crédence
sur le nombre de cas qu'il y aura ne pas
sous-estimer l'étendue de notre
ignorance est ici critique pour se
rendre compte que des quatre très
extrême demeure possible
vraiment je n'insisterai jamais
suffisamment dessus mais la croissance
exponentielle c'est ultra ultra ultra
contre intuitif c'est à dire que ça va à
l'encontre de l'intuition et donc qu'il
faut se méfier de votre intuition qui ne
faut pas autres en excès de confiance
sur notre compréhension de la croissance
exponentielle
faites moi même quand j'ai écrit le
script de cette vidéo et quand j'ai joué
avec cette cour bloc normal j'ai été
surpris à de très nombreuses reprises
par les calculs que je faisais
personnellement même après avoir passé
des années à prétendre que nous
sous-estimons tous gravement la
croissance exponentielle je me rends
compte chaque jour que je suis restée
gravement la compréhension de la
croissance exponentielle et
malheureusement je ne pense pas être le
seul
les experts en épidémiologie aussi me
semble avoir dangereusement surestimer
leur compréhension de la croissance
exponentielle mais alors vous qui me
regarder pensez vous avoir une
compréhension suffisante de cette
croissance exponentielle
ok ça c'était la première remarque sur
exponentielle mais il ya beaucoup plus
préoccupant encore les intervalles de
crédence exprimées par les experts
semblent être sensé représenter des
intervalles à 80% autrement dit ils
devraient être valide 80% du temps
cependant quel que soit le nombre de cas
confirmés qu'il y aura on peut montrer
avec ce graphe qu'il y aura au plus aux
intervalles valide
en effet peu importe où vous tracez la
droite verticale du nombre de cas
confirmés le 29 mars
il est impossible d'intercepter 12
intervalle de crédence des experts et ça
c'est catastrophique
ça montre que même dans le meilleur des
cas au plus 11/18 soit 61% des
intervalles de crédence à 80% seront
valides
voilà qui paraît complètement honteux
les intervalles de crédence des experts
à 80% sont tels qu'il est impossible
qu'ils soient valides 80% du temps en
fait ce que cela montre surtout c'est
que les marges d'erreur que les experts
estiment sont nécessairement beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup trop étroite
elles ne tiennent pas suffisamment en
compte l'étendue de leur ignorance
ainsi rien qu'en voyant ce graphe on
peut affirmer que les experts sont
nécessairement globalement en excès de
confiance
bon ok tout ça c'est une analyse que
j'aurais pu avoir fait au moment de la
publication du sondage est que j'ai
d'ailleurs fait dans le cas du sondage
des experts en ia sur la probabilité d'y
à deux niveaux humain avec des
conclusions tout aussi désastreuse
concernant l'excès de confiance
les experts mais là cette fois on a
chance de pouvoir comparer les
prédictions des experts aux données du
29 mars
où est le nombre de cas confirmés aux
états unis le 29 mars
d'après vous juste en regardant ce grade
ou pensez-vous que le nombre de cas
confirmés se situe est-ce qu'il est ici
ou là et bien vous pouvez vérifier sur
le site co vyntra king.com slash us
délit et voir que le nombre de cas
confirmés le 29 mars et 139000 et sur le
graphe 139000 c'est ici ce graphe
il m'a vraiment mis hors de moi pendant
plusieurs jours j'ai même eu beaucoup de
mal à croire quand ce graphe connaissant
notamment les travaux de philippe club
je m'attendais probablement un excès de
confiance des épidémiologistes
mais je n'imaginais pas une seconde que
surtout des mois après le début de cette
pandémie
les experts soit encore aussi mauvais
pour mesurer l'étendue de leur ignorance
en fait j'ai longtemps suspecté que le
graff correspondent à des prédictions le
23 mars
comme rapporté dans le premier point de
la publication des auteurs du sondage
mais la journaliste de failles forty
eight qui a fait ce graphe m'assurer que
non ce graphe correspond bien au 29 mars
est donc à des informations qui n'ont
pas été écrites et dans les publications
des auteurs du sondage est d'ailleurs ce
graphe et bien cohérent avec une
citation d'un experts interviewés dans
l'article de faille sortir it qui estime
et des temps de doublement de 5 à 8
jours
mais cette estimation des experts ne
connais absolument pas aux données à
l'exception des pays asiatiques qui ont
pris des mesures drastiques qui n'ont
clairement pas été mise en place aux
états unis la plupart des pays ont connu
une progression beaucoup plus rapide du
coc vide 19 n'avoir même pas envisager
la probabilité que ce cas puisse arriver
aux états unis me paraît extrêmement
décevant de la part des experts en fait
seulement 3 des 18 intervalle de
crédence contiennent le nombre de cas
effectivement confirmé seulement 16% des
intervalles de crédence à 80% sont
valides
c'est catastrophique catastrophe
mais ce n'est pas tout quatorze des
dix-huit intervalles sont même
complètement à côté de la plaque
l'erreur associés à leurs prédictions
semblent être de plus de 5 sigma et même
souvent de plus de 10 si demain de la
bonne réponse
si chaque expert était une hypothèse
elle serait très largement rejetées par
les statistiques fréquentes east y
compris selon les standards de la
physique des particules
au terme d'un désir il ne s'agit bien
sûr pas de rejeter les experts cependant
ceci questionne violemment leur
expertise
le rapport de vraisemblance entre un
modèle idiot d'extrapolation de la
croissance exponentielle avec grosse
incertitude sur le taux de croissance
est l'avis des experts est de l'ordre du
million voire de 10 puissance fin
autrement dit quoi que disent les
experts pourvu que j'ai à côté une
simple prédictions par extrapolation
d'une exponentielle la formule de bayes
m'invita désormais quasiment ignoré
l'avis de ces experts
en pratique c'est même pire que ça
encore parce que ce qui a été ignorée
par les experts ce n'est pas ici un
meilleur cas ça serait assez excusable
il s'agit ici d'ignorer les pires cas
l'écrasante majorité des experts a
complètement ignoré la possibilité des
cas radicalement pire que celui du
modèle qu'ils avaient dans leur cerveau
autrement dit ils n'ont pas du tout
adopter le cetim en fait c'est à dire le
réflexe de penser au pire cas pour se
préparer à des catastrophes auxquelles
la plupart des gens n'ont même pas pensé
or ne pas prêté suffisamment d'attention
risques de catastrophes
c'est un peu une catastrophe car dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
ces catastrophes ne sont pas si rares et
il faut s'y préparer en particulier si
les politiciens ont écouté de tels
experts ce n'est alors pas étonnant que
les politiciens ne se sont pas préparé
adéquatement à la catastrophe que l'on
vit alors bien sûr je ne dis pas cela
pour dédouaner les experts les
journalistes les vulgarisateurs ou et
citoyens il y a beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent et qu'ils doivent être améliorés
pour limiter autant que possible les
dégâts sanitaires sociaux et économiques
de la crise actuelle il semble urgent
que tout le monde prenne surtout
beaucoup plus de temps pour
s'autocritiquer plutôt que de rejeter la
faute aux autres comme c'est sans doute
bien trop systématiquement le cas
actuellement en particulier il semble
urgent que chaque
un d'entre nous fasse beaucoup plus
attention à notre excès de confiance car
ces jours ci plus encore que d'habitude
l'excès de confiance tu y compris notre
propre excès de confiance
le mien est le vôtre alors avant de
conclure je vais quand même insisté sur
une circonstance atténuante des experts
à cause de la stigmatisation de
l'alarmisme et de l'apel récurrent à ne
pas faire paniquer la population
il est possible que consciemment ou
inconsciemment les experts ont fait des
prédictions plus rassurante que ce qu'il
pense vraiment on parle de biais de
respectabilité
l'expert a une pression sociale pour
paraître respectable or l'alarmisme est
souvent associée à un comportement non
respectable peut-être que les experts ou
ici péché par biais de respectabilité
ça expliquerait en partie leurs énormes
sous-estimation de la pandémie et ça
pourrait peut-être aussi expliquer leurs
excès de confiance
malheureusement dans nos sociétés dans
les médias et sur les réseaux sociaux
pour l'instant en tout cas exprimé une
grande incertitude semble dévalorisé on
semble avoir tendance à encourager
consciemment ou non les gens à avoir un
avis tranché et précis et a ignoré voire
à moquer ceux qui étalent l'étendue de
leur ignorance
pire encore on a une bien fâcheuse
tendance à attribuer plus de crédence à
ceux qui parle avec assurance avec des
discours simple et plein de confiance en
soi
trop souvent ce sont les tweets
tranchant univoque et souvent cassan qui
récoltent nos like pas ceux qui
s'expriment avec nuance doutes et
incertitudes et qui utilise le hashtag
c'est compliqué et ça c'est fort dommage
parce que du coup on pousse tout notre
entourage tous nos proches nos amis nos
collègues nos politiciens nos médias nos
vulgarisateur nous-mêmes et même nos
scientifiques à être dans l'excès de
confiance
voilà qui est non seulement
problématique insatisfaisant mais à
l'heure actuelle c'est surtout même
dangereux car l'excès de confiance tu
donc je vous
en supplie après avoir vu cette vidéo
quand vous retournerez sur facebook ou
twitter
je vous en supplie faites attention à
cela ignorer les messages tranché
univoque et cassant les garder à
l'esprit que chaque like ou partage d'un
message en excès de confiance est un
encouragement à davantage d'excès de
confiance non seulement pour la personne
leaké mais aussi pour tous ceux qui vont
voir votre like au lieu d'entretenir et
d'encourager la culture de l'excès de
confiance je vous en supplie je vous en
supplie faites l'effort de davantage
laïque et partager et commenter les
commentaires qui sont bienveillants
nuancé et plein de modestie épistémique
et s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît je
vous en supplie avant d'envoyer vos
tweets et vos posts facebook
relisez ce que vous écrivez et ajouter
des marqueurs de modestie épistémique
ajouter un petit il me semble que où je
me trompe peut-être quand vous débattre
et de ce qu'il va arriver du nombre de
cas du coc vie de 19 à venir de
l'efficacité des différentes
interventions pour battre coville 19 de
la durée de confinement de la
probabilité d'un seconde confinement des
conséquences socio-économiques d'un
confinement prolongées ou répétées il
des risques politiques que des tensions
exacerbées du comité 19 peuvent soulever
de ce qu'il aurait fallu faire de ce
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui et de ce
qu'il faudra faire dans les mois qui
viennent et en particulier surtout de ce
que vous devez faire dès à présent s'il
vous plaît je vous en supplie prenez le
temps de mesurer l'étendue de votre
ignorance et penser à envisager les
pires cas et leur probabilité s'il vous
plaît pensez à adopter le cesti 27 et à
lutter contre votre excès de confiance
après tout au final les experts qui ont
brillé dans cette prédiction ceux qui
ont gagné en créances se sont en fait
ceux qui ont étalé l'étendue de leur
ignorance
finalement ce qui mérite notre confiance
ce sont peut être davantage ceux qui ne
dégagent pas d'excès de confiance
j'espère que cette vidéo vous
béchir si vous l'avez aimée penser à
laquer à commentaire partagé pense que
vous avez vous été présenté sur épisode
merci aussi peur pour leurs dons et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois
[Musique]